john smoltz was on the call last night
courtesy of uh fox sports and uh he
joins us now
some festivities there a little
fireworks there some bad blood there as
well
what did you take away from this uh game
last night
yeah definitely i think without the fans
right you got to generate your own
intensity and your and
and i've seen that the teams that have
the most excitement in their
in their uh dugouts it may not always be
received well because we don't typically
get to hear
the bantering going back and forth well
guess what you can hear just about
everything
and as a broadcaster you know all i
could have done is said look here i'm
throwing my mask
i mean that's all i could have done but
i i i could check a couple things off of
my
my list of things i've never seen i've
never seen a glove throw that
that that long other than uh jesse
orozco maybe when he threw his up to the
sky
and they won the whole thing that their
series so
uh yeah i kind of agreed i echoed the
same
sentiments of what mookie betts said you
know the only thing you just can't have
in this game you can't have it both ways
you gotta
be able to take what comes back at you
when you show that kind of emotion and
i'm fine with the emotion
uh it's just the emotion sometimes is
trying to create
something for your team because you're
behind and you hope it had carryover
effect and it looked like it did because
they went back
to back on the homers okay but the
dodger pitcher who's celebrating
yeah gave up a home run like if
bellinger doesn't bring it back like
right he can't celebrate he didn't
strike out the side
no no he was he was a bomb john yeah he
did he did
he gave up what was turned into one of
the best catches you're going to see in
a while and i think he was so excited
that his
his teammate caught caught it uh that um
yeah but he's blowing kisses to the
padres doug out there
i get it i mean i i guess here's the
thing that i've always said
you know when you when you watch
baseball and you see the
uh exuberant celebrations on home runs
the unbelievable
uh backflips why i ask you this question
okay
why does the hitters only get to do it
you never see
we look at trevor bauer and he's the uh
outlier
when he walks off the mountain the way
he does i think as pitchers
as a group of pitchers it's time that
they start showing some excitement
i i i did the pascal perez thing you
know back in the day
a little shimmy when yeah i got a chance
to strike him out
no it's all it's all good and i'm i'm
okay with pictures
dennis eckersley used to you know shoot
you down
you're next get out yeah we need more of
that i guess
i i love it i i'm i'm fine with all of
that
i want baseball to be a celebration i
know
john you got to get kids watching i'm
not saying be gimmicky
but if i'm a kid and i'm watching
it doesn't move people throw really hard
and swing really hard other than that
there's no joy in mudville
and that's my biggest concern with
baseball is
how do you create an atmosphere if i'm a
10 year old a 12 year old
because you're you know your demo is in
the 50s probably
mid 50s you got to create something that
if i'm
a sports fan why am i watching this well
you're watching it because
these guys have fun tatis love it i love
it
you know you want to do that bad flip if
you got a guy on the mound who's
striking people out
punching you out i'm good with that as
well have fun every other sport does
yeah and that that's my only point it's
like it's it's only kind of
the hitters that get to do it and i and
and look
uh if a pitcher started doing it it
would probably be a little bit more
entertaining um because they have the
opportunity to do it
a few more times to the same batter but
it's it's interesting how the only thing
i would say is that the context of
sometimes
you can't get mad if the other the other
team's going to do something you just
can't that's the only thing
and in the heat of the moment of course
you can always have your uh
your all right we'll give them a break
type thing but
when i when i when i saw the glove toss
i got to be that's the first
and if he had the insight to be able to
do that based on the bat tossed like to
do that
that quickly that would be um i gotta
give him some props
i understand that the dodgers absolutely
love this kid
and and certainly if you throw 100 and
you got a wipeout slider like he does
um i guess it's uh easy to love them
would you rather
hit a game-winning home run or have the
game-winning catch like if if you could
have had
bellinger's catch to win a game or a
home run a walk-off
i've always said you know um i've robbed
more home runs than any pitcher in the
history of the game right i mean that's
that's a fact um because i kept track in
in shagging fly balls but i would much
rather
rob a home run i think that's one of the
coolest plays we rarely get to see
if i were commissioner i would make sure
every stadium uh
except boston you can't really change
that wall
i would make sure every fence has a
chance for a guy to rob a home run i
think it's one of the most exciting
plays
the game-winning home run there's just
so much more of them
that that catch last night look that's a
game-changing
kind of series changer yeah and in a
short series yeah if that's the best of
seven
in game two ah you know you got much
more time to
kind of rebound from it that's g that's
a that's a basically game two
uh of a best of five and that's much
more difficult to come back from
i had a couple of notes as i was
watching the game last night first of
all the ballpark itself so you have two
teams
that aren't used you know it's not their
home field there
and and are do you play differently
now that you're in this bubble and
you're not able to be in
your ball i mean the dodgers would at
least be familiar with the padres
ballpark
and here you are in a a different
ballpark and
how does strategy change for these two
teams i think the biggest thing
is uh you know you're you're look i mean
the ball is jumping out of those
other two ballparks that they play in uh
than the other series so there's 18 home
runs in la and
what 15 home runs in san diego so the
familiarity of when you hit a ball
is pretty obvious to those guys here
they're getting used to
okay this was the first night that the
bulb
actually carried a little bit we saw
some homers go
over the fence it's a big ballpark it's
a really really beautiful park
and i think you would play differently
from a base running standpoint because
the gaps are huge
defensively you're going to have to
cover more so those things come into
play
um but what what a great venue and i
think both both clubs
i've talked about how uh you know big
the ballpark is and
and certainly they've squared up some
balls that got caught so if you
if you have some defense out there in
center field especially you're going to
make you're going to take away a lot of
runs
talking to john smoltz the hall of famer
working for fox sports
you had the call last night with the
dodgers and padres uh you talked about
clayton kershaw
some of these pitchers have their own
catcher explain
how a catcher is that much different for
for a pitcher
well the familiarity of of of just being
on the same page right there are times
that you aren't on the same page and
that continuity kind of
affects the flow and when you know
there's a guy back there that's thinking
along the same lines of you and he's
doing your work
he's doing his work and you've done
yours and they match up that is that is
something that's hard to explain to the
viewer that why that's so important you
would think
that um throwing to anybody based on
your stuff would be okay but the way a
guy catches the ball the way he frames
it the way his setup is can be appealing
and and on the opposite side it can be a
little awkward when you don't see things
the same way
a bigger catcher for example might not
frame well i've thrown to a lot of
different catchers and there is a
difference between the way they set up
how they receive
and how you're on the same page you
don't want to be out there shaking your
head a lot
you want to be able to be in rhythm how
do you tell the other catcher that you
don't want him
uh you know the numbers will speak
pretty uh obviously i think the
disparity of the era between the two
catchers
and not that will smith's not a great
catcher was pretty high and sometimes
the sample size isn't
isn't good but i think that comes to the
manager uh i've only had
one instance where i i felt compelled to
go to bobby cox and go
give me the kid give me brian mccann it
just happened to work out we won seven
games in a row
he stayed up in the big leagues and the
rest was history for him
history for him but you've seen over the
course of time that pitchers definitely
are comfortable with
i guess quote unquote personal catchers
the only the other thing you'll hear is
hey we need to give uh so and so a day
off so he just happens to be the guy
that kind of
what were the yankees doing in the
previous game not the one they lost last
night because i think they may have lost
the series
by trying to be too smart to out raise
the raise with you know the lineup
right hand left hand that whole thing
yeah i'm not sure i mean obviously when
you make those decisions you feel like
they're the right decisions at the
moment and you hope they all work out
but you know what we're seeing is a kind
of uh
a confluence if you will between the
organizations that have
um in this setup which we have never
seen with no off days have the ability
to be able to go deep in a series which
gives them the advantage depth wise
i i in my memory i don't remember too
many series where you go in and go we
don't have a fourth or a fifth starter
and in some cases we didn't have a third
starter
but the yankees kind of have that and to
your point i i'm a little intrigued with
why they
set up you know the situation the way
they did and you're right
if if they don't win this game i'm
assuming that
garrett cole would pitch game five yeah
but this format
is really going to either shed light
on some things or expose some things for
these clubs
i just think it gives the team with the
best depth the best chance to move
forward and you might
very well say the race have the best
depth in the american league for sure
yeah i i have the rays in the dodgers in
the world series but if you said that it
was going to be the dodgers and astros
i'd sign up for that right now well the
story lines there'd be a lot to talk
about right i mean there would be you
want to talk about
um the emotion and the things that
you're going to see now at that point
we'll still we'll have some fans which
would be nice
it won't be a packed house but at least
some but not
home ball parks right correct yeah
correct and and i think
look i understand i totally understand
where the astros are as a team
i just think it's hard sometimes you you
gotta bite your tongue
and and you just gotta prove it you just
gotta go out and prove it and that's
what they're doing they're
playing great team baseball they've lost
a lot of stars
and certainly the narrative is going to
be one that you really can't speak to if
you're them
um because it just has one of those you
just know when
you know scenarios attached to it yeah
and i don't want to hear from them
i don't want it to be hey you know can
you criticize us now
if if you could play this way then why
did you cheat
that was that's still what i keep coming
back to if you're this
good we thought you were this good then
why did you cheat
yeah and again like i said it's it's
this year we'll come and go we'll we'll
find out
a champion we'll be able to talk about i
think the hardest road
road to a champion ever i think that the
world series winner is going to have a
uh no asterix and by the way probably
the hardest journey
that they've ever had not even taking
into considerations the covet journey
it's just the tournament itself present
presents so many
uh tough obstacles and i and i'll say
this nobody has more pressure than the
dodgers
and the second most team that has the
pressure is probably the yankees
um but nobody has had more pressure in
the dodgers and they've handled it so
far
incredibly well yeah i just get a sense
of when they win it's relief
not celebration yeah that's that's a
good
it's a good depiction of where they're
at because you think about that first
series
is a scary uh best of three and then
this series of course
with it's rare that you have the two
best records playing this early but
that's the way it's set up and
and it just so happens the padres have
unfortunately lost some key pitching
yeah uh to to not be able to mix and
match the way they thought they could
against
you know the bullies of their uh
division because for the last five years
they've had their
their way with the padres and it's a new
it's going to be a new next five years
uh in the in the west there's certain
pictures you know i thought pedro
had his sandy kofax moment he had like
five or six years which he was just
incredible in the american league in
that ballpark you know obviously sandy
koufax
you you pitched with maddox on your team
kershaw's had that run as well does
kershaw fit
in with those guys with having that five
six year window that is historical
oh absolutely i i mean i
when when i do a game you know you dive
back into the numbers and you gotta
check it like three times go
really this is his career numbers it
doesn't seem
it just seems like it's a video game and
i think to his credit what he's been
able to do
over the course of his career in in this
era
he's the perfect pitcher that could
pitch in any era like they talk about
certain pitchers
15 years ago they couldn't pitch today
they're probably right but
in the sense that this era is a swing
and miss and homer era he has still
dominated because he's figured out how
to do that
and i'll tell you the one thing you know
i know we're going to all talk about his
post seasons ups and downs
but you watch at the end of his career
it's going to be more up than it is down
and
that's the one thing keep giving the
ball on the guy in this in this time
frame and he's going to deliver
i think it's a great point and i was i
was thinking about that that i wanted to
ask you as i watch him and he gets so
many swings and misses
and in this game now it is a swing and
either connect or miss you don't put the
ball in play
and to have that ability you know he was
topping out at like 92 i think on his
fastball but
you know that's just to kind of keep you
honest there you know that with those
breaking balls and these guys swinging
for the downs there
you know i don't ma how would maddox
have been in today's game
where he wanted you to put the ball in
play i
i i love this question and i and i will
argue with anybody
who thinks that he would get beat up
there's no way he would absolutely
dominate in this era
the one thing about the style of hitting
is there's no adjustments right so
i get the fact that the easiest way to
score is to hit a home run
so you wait for a mistake you don't have
to alter your swing and you and you mash
them
he's not going to give you a chance to
get the ball on the area where you want
to and that's the one difference between
the style of pitching today where
you live in the zone with stuff because
the stuff is phenomenal
but when you make a mistake it goes a
long way and i just don't think greg
makes a lot of mistakes i watched over
the course of his career just carve guys
up
on the corners and be able to get them
to chase velocity
then change speeds and i think that's
the one you know it's
very difficult to transcend kind of eras
i wish we could do it and we could do it
statistically but you can't do it
in your mind to think like oh this guy
would get killed and this guy would do
this
i know his strikeouts would go up and
his homers would go up but i don't think
he would suffer
because the style of hitting would cause
him to suffer it would be his pitching
that would expose the style of hitting
john of course uh in the hall of fame
but you did have three career stolen
bases
oh yeah didn't you steal third ones you
know
i was i was a before people ever
got to know me as a pitcher i was the
official pinch runner when i got called
up under russ nixon
and i still talk about one of the most
infamous moments of where i pinched ran
in san diego
and i was called earlier than i was
prepared for because i didn't have my
spikes on i had my turf sheet
and i and i say this all the time i had
milk duds i was enjoying a great game in
the dugout
and i got called in and i couldn't find
my helmet jody davis was at first
i had to shove the box of milk dugs in
my back pocket
and it took about five minutes to get a
helmet i realized as i was running out
he had my helmet we switched helmets i
got to first benito santiago was behind
the plague so i was scared to death to
get picked off
i got thrown out at second by uh just a
little bit on a
on a i think it was a bun and i slid on
my milk duds and i got
chewed out later by my manager for not
having spikes
so but i say all that that i did have
speed back then and no it doesn't look
like
it didn't look like it i did but i have
yeah three stolen bases in my career
in the postseason i have a stolen base
too of course you do yeah only
have that yeah not many pitchers have a
stolen base in the post season did i
tell you i've robbed back-to-back homers
on back-to-back pitches in uh
in vp that's still i mean i just thought
i'd throw that out there it's hard to do
back to back
no people still talk about that oh good
yeah and i have a baseball card robbing
a home run
baseball guy i'm not gonna bring up the
barry bonds home run or anything like
that
yeah they should probably shouldn't he
did do it though he said what he was
going to do and he did it
and you threw and you threw a great
pitch
[Laughter]
twice yes it's always a great pitch man
he hit a great pitch there you know
nobody ever says man he hit a crappy
pitch there uh
john will be on the call with a matt
vasquezian uh tonight game three
padres dodgers at nine eastern
exclusively on mlb network and then game
four potential game five where on uh air
on fox sports
one great to talk to you we'll be uh
watching tonight john
you got it thank you thank you that's uh
johnny swans hall of famer